نبره فيها تهديد انا ما اعتقد انه قد هذه
المسؤوليه انه يقولها لا انا قدها وقدود
لما لما تكلم انت اللي تسكت وفي مشهد
سيبحث على جدران الذاكره العربيه ها هو
تميم يغادر دون القاء السلام وبشار يقول
لن نضيع تلك الفرصه الذهبيه بينما
السعوديه في الزاويه المقابله تعلن عن
حضانه عدو بوتين الاول موسكو تتابع بصمت
واصحاب العيون الضيقه يحضرون الفشار
بانتظار كلمه زيلينسكي في القمه العربيه
لماذا غادر تميم بن حمد القاعه غاضبا وما
الذي اتى بزالينزكي ليجلس بين حلفاء موسكو
من العرب ويتحدث بكل جراه هل هي خطه خبيثه
من بن سلمان الهدف منها اعاده الود مع
امريكا ام انها كانت خطوه غير مدروسه
ستكلف السعوديه الكثير او ربما خطه روسيه
سعوديه الهدف منها تعالوا لتغادروا بخفاي
حنين لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع
الفيديو للنهايه
مسرح المفاجاه
حتى وان ذهبت بعض القمم في طي النسيان فان
قمه جد لن تلقى نفس المصير وربما ستظل
محفوره في ذاكره التاريخ فقد كانت قمه
عربيه ولكنها ليست عربيه بالكامل مفاجات
عديده واخرى صادمه لا احد يفهم شيئا مما
يحدث في جده في حين وقف ولي العهد السعودي
محمد بن سلمان كما لو كان ساحرا يكشف
الغطاء عن العديد من المفاجات الواحده تلو
الاخرى امام ذهول المشاهدين الذي لم ينقطع
طوال فتره الجلسه ها هو بشار الاسد يجلس
على مقعد سوريا في القمه العربيه بعد
مقاطعه دامت لنحو 13 عاما وفي تلك اللحظه
كان الحكيم الصيني هو الغائب الحاضر فعوده
سوريا الاسد الى الصف العربي لم تكن لتحدث
الا لتنفيذ بن سلمان لنصيحه الرئيس الصيني
تشيين عندما قال له ان عليه ان يتبع سياسه
الصفر خلافات اذا اراد مستقبلا رائعا
فتصالحت الرياض مع دمشق ليجلس بشار الاسد
على مقعد بلاده في القمه العربيه من جديد
ولكن يبدو انك لن تستطيع ارضاء الجميع
فقبل بدء كلمه الاسد في القمه فوجئ الجميع
بامير قطارت من بن حمد يقف ويغادر مع وفده
القاعه ومنها الى الدوحه دون حتى سابق
انذار لم يستغرق التصرف القطري وقتا طويلا
لتفسيره فالمياه الراكده بين الدوحه ودمشق
لم تتحرك او تصفو بعد لدرجه ان تميم لم
يتحمل الجلوس والاستماع الى صوت الاسد ولو
للحظات قليله وما اكد ذلك تصريح وزير
الخارجيه القطري الذي قال فيه ان قطر قد
تخلت عن معارضتها لعوده سوريا للجماعه
لانها لا تريد الخروج عن الاجماع العربي
اي ان قبول قطر لعوده سوريا لا يعني تصفيه
الخلافات بينهما لتدخل امريكا على خط
الازمه قائله لا نعتقد ان سوريا تستح ق
العوده الى الجامعه العربيه وهنا السؤال
هل ستكون الدوحه عائقا امام سياسه سفر
خلافات التي تتبناها الرياض حاليا يبدو ان
طريق السعوديه لانهاء كل خلافاتها لن يكون
مفروشا بالحرير
ضيف غريب كانت المفاجاه الثانيه التي كشف
عنها بن سلمان الغطاء اغرب من ان يصدقها
ان يعقل فقد فشئ الزعماء العرب بوجود
الرئيس الاوكراني
بينهم اتيا بدعوه من المملكه يا الهي ماذا
يحدث ماذا يفعل رئيس اوكرانيا في قاعه
القمه العربيه بل قل ماذا يفعل عدو بوتين
الاول في قاعه يجتمع فيها اغلب حلفاء
روسيا من العرب لا احد يفهم شيئا وليس
حضور الرئيس الاوكراني كان هادئا فقد كان
يجلس امام بشار الاسد الذي ايد غزو روسيا
لاوكرانيا علنا ليستغل زيلينس كالقمه
ويقوم باتهام العديد من الدول العربيه
بالتواطئ مع روسيا وتغاضيها عن الهجوم
الروسي لبلاده قائلا لسوء الحرب هناك
البعض في العالم وهنا من بينكم من يغضون
الطرف عن اقفاص اسرى الحرب والضم غير
القانوني لاراضي اوكرانيه انا هنا حتى
الجميع من معرفه ما يجري بنظره صادقه بغض
النظر عن مدى صعوبه محاوله الروس التاثير
فلا يزال هناك استقلالا ثم طالب الزعماء
العرب بمساعده شعبه وحمايه الجاليه
الاوكرانيه المسلمه ليزداد الوضع توترا
وحيره بين كل الحاضرين كان وجود الرئيس
الاوكراني مفاجاه صادمه للجميع وكان
اجتماع العرب ليس للعرب ناهيك عن غرابه
موقف محمد بن سلمان فاحتضان جده لعدو
بوتين الاول ربما يتم فهمه على انه تحدي
من السعوديه لروسيا او اعلان السعوديه
الحياد في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه او قل
حرب روسيا ضد امريكا والغرب وهذا في احسن
الاحوال ولكن بماذا برر بن سلمان موقفه
وهل تقبل موسكو حياد السعوديه في حربها
الكبرى تبرير السعوديه ورساله موسكو وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
قال مبررا دعوته للرئيس الاوكراني دعوتنا
لفخامه الرئيس زلينسكي هي من باب سماع
وجهه نظر جميع الاطراف كنا منخرطين في فتح
الحوار مع الطرفين املا في ان نستطيع
الوصول الى سبيل يفتح الباب للحل من خلال
الحوار يبدو ان الرياض تريد ان تلعب دور
الوسيط المحوري لحل الازمه وانهاء الحرب
ولكن هل سيسمح الدب الروسي للسعوديه بذلك
لم يعلق بوتين على احتضان جده للرئيس
الاوكراني بل وارسل برقيه للقمه العربيه
تحدث فيها عن الصراعات والازمات الاخرى
التي تناولها الزعماء العرب مؤكدا دعمه في
القضيه الفلسطينيه وحل الصراع في السودان
وانهاء الازمه الليبيه واليمنيه وتعاونه
مع الدول العربيه على اوسع نطاق كل هذا
دون ان يتطرق الى وجود زيلينسكي بين العرب
ولكن هل يعني ذلك ان بوتين سوف يتغاضى عن
وج الرئيس الاوكراني بين حلفاء روسيا
فادح قد يكلف الكثير
يبدو ان دعوه السعوديه للرئيس الاوكراني
قد اغضبت الدب الروسي الذي لا يعرف المزاح
فقد ذهب بعض المحللين الى القول بان وجود
زيلينسكي في جده كان خطا فادحا ومغامره
غير مدروسه من بن سلمان وانه من الواضح ان
الرياض تسعى الى زياده دورها في الشؤون
الدوليه وكانها تريد ان تلعب دور الشرطي
المنطقه ويرى المحلل الروسي الكسندر نظره
انما فعلته الرياض لم يكن له اي داع بل
وربما يقلب عليها الطاوله رغم انها لا
تحتاج الى التفاوض مع كيام الا انها
تعاملت بشكل ايجابي مع الوساطه السعودي
واعطت الرياضه الفرصه للتباهي بالافراج عن
المرتزقه الاجانب من فوج ازوف النازي
الاوكراني الذي كانت روسيا قد اعتقلته
سابقا كما ان دعوه السعوديه
تفهم على انها محاوله من اجل التملق
لوشنطن وحتى تخ الاخيره ضغوطها فيما يتعلق
بالتقارب السعودي الصيني وتطبيع علاقاتها
مع ايران وحتى سوريا الاسد لذا فان وجود
زيلينسكي على اراضي السعوديه يثير الشكوك
بان تقاربها مع الصين وانهاء حاله الغذاء
مع ايران وسوريا وتطبيع العلاقات معهما كل
هذا قد لا يكون تحولا حقيقيا في سياسه
المملكه نحو استقلال اكبر في الشؤون
الدوليه وخروجها من عباءه واشنطن وانما
مجرد عنصر مساومه مع امريكا من اجل رفع
قدر ومكانه السعوديه في قائمه الاولويات
الامريكيه فالدعم السعودي والعربي حتى وان
كان معنىويا فقط فانه يصب في صالح واشنطن
ويجعلها تخفض من تكاليف دعمها لكياب
وتحويل معظم هذه التكاليف الى الدول
التابعه لها وبهذا تصبح الرياض سببا
اساسيا في تخفيف عبء كبير عن امريكا
وبالتالي زياده قوتها في مواجهه بوتين
ويضيف المحلل الروسي قائلا ان منح
السعوديه لزينسكي فرصه للحديث عن اراضيها
لن يخدم دور المملكه في الوساطه بل على
العكس ربما يوقفه تماما كما انه لن يؤدي
الى اي شيء سوى زياده الحرب ضراوه ومعاناه
السكان وخساره الجميع والان هل ترى ان
دعوه بن سلمان
ستقفز بالمملكه الى مركز اعلى في قائمه
الدول الكبرى ام انها كانت خطا جسيما
استفز به بوتين وستدفع الرياض ثمنا غاليا